you taking me to school again
and picking you up part of some drill
ain't no drill 19 men attacked our
country the 12 of you will be the first
ones to fight back how do you love your
family and leave them to go to war I
have two hours I'll be really quick not
a chance
holding out is the only way I can
guarantee you come back to me what's
gonna be only a week every step we take
he's gonna be in a minefield from a
hundred different wars odds are we're
not all gonna make it out of this we
don't take that City World Trade Center
it's just the beginning
teaming up the general of the Northern
Alliance we know nothing about general
you show me exactly where we're going
what are the mountains we take horses
alright who's ridden before anyone
summer camp when I was nine spring break
but I was pretty hammered does have a
name the name gray this is we slug we're
outnumbered
fifty thousand Taliban okay two fibers
we're on our own I can't order anyone to
do this do you want to surrender keep
your finger on the trigger there's no
playbook here we have to write it
ourselves
oh I ain't losing one man honest to you
could stand me up
pather case of whoa
we're fighting with horsemen against
tanks
[Music]
the greatest weapon in history is this
very no easy way and if you die that's a
letter you and your wife are gonna wish
you wrote
your folks will come
[Music]
at 12 strong the Declassified true story
of the horse soldiers
[Music]
you